war was going to assign another fate
command a section of an
infantry regiment the 106th fight see his
friends die hold on be wounded and have to
leave his brothers finally write
write with all the tenderness of which a
man is capable
write to give a name a voice  quite
unknown dead as a hero
maurice genevoix was going to be the writer
of war and death on the banks
of the meuse then the writer of nature
and freedom of the meanders of the
loire crowned with an immense work
crowned with  a goncourt prize consecrated
perpetual secretary of the
french academy he remained no less faithful
to his dear hairy men in the trenches he
offered them the immortality of words death
had separated and maurice genevoix and his
comrades for a long time his family his
loved ones
number of  its shameful readers true so that
they find themselves thus some
in the meantime have fallen on other
fields of horror hoping for it the
republic
today brings them all together for
eternity
they are there those of 14 were first
the fighters of joy
and innocence in the summer the men in
blue coats and red pants go to
war
he walks in the French countryside
to join the front he sings
sometimes laughs often finds his
legs and heart still light
they hope to return quickly
victorious alive but he
soon discovers the horror from September 1914 on
his husband the terrible din everywhere
of shells exploding men who
die not resembling  no longer to
men of the mutilated who are dying
on the side of the roads the countryside
ravaging the earth a thousand times gutted
the writing in the distance the fields of mud
put two corpses in the chaos
despite everything moments except
despair life resists
the brothers  not so rare the letters
received the laughter the discussions the
owl of the church of the savings the coffee
which warms the body delivered what
sustains the forces these moments
suspended or Geneva and po  rsche have
lamy also come from the loire delirium
of happiness because one is finally they
writhe in a real bed above all
there is the fraternity which unites these men
they did not know each other but
discover in the trenches the same
love of the  fatherland the same taste for
freedom he endures horror
shoulder to shoulder shoulder to shoulder with the same
courage with himself fear wherever they
come from
there is no longer any social distinction
of difference in the face of the
just chaos of  comrades so when
the moment comes each evening when the
living must meet and count themselves they close
ranks again to
share all that they have left the
warmth of their miserable bodies together
they cling to a few acres of
land taken  one day and which will
perhaps be resumed the next day
absurdity of it's me or the offensives
are launched on pieces of hill
that we had just lost or the trench
soon mingle with the bowels of the
earth or the soil  l de france that we are
recovering meter by meter and the
shroud of the brothers in arms that they
had lost on the crest of the eparges
in the spring of 1915
the steel storms rumble unceasingly
as later in the sum at the chemin
des dames  in verdun where neither lives
thousands of men lose their youth
their comrades their reasons often
their life
robert porsche we fall there at 21
a little later genevois is hit in
turn three times the stretcher
the infirmary life saves
the war  du lieutenant je le voir is
over but his work begins with his
comrades
maurice genevoix wants to give back names
of faces accents to offer these
ordinary heroes and so bravo a
tomb of memory in the French language
those of 14 and the field of the will
of  a nation the fortitude of
an entire people
the life and death notebook of
the unspeakable the story of women
and men driven by courage the courage of
those who know why they are
fighting  I was the same one who had
raised this of 1789 the volunteers
of year 2 of all our wars the courage
of all our soldiers
the same one also who allowed us to
build a few decades later with
our europe the peace that we
owed them no  not a defeat of cowardice
and renunciation but that of a
constant dialogue respectful of our
stories as of our differences
demanding for our values they enter here
oday
finally the unknown soldier and the g
lden books of the whole village had t
be a time  converging under this nave
on this day we bring them together pushes
through the sepulcher of maurice
genevoix through his comrades their name their
life and by recreating this unique place the
palimpsest pantheon of our nation by
the works danson kieffer which tell the
mystique of his wanderings  nocturnal
stellar destinies lives shattered
between sky and earth
the vestiges of a daily life where the language
of Geneva appears in echo
barbed clothes bicycle fl  ers lost in the
mud ears of wheat tangible story book
presents the courage to reinvent in the
material by the rooms
dedicated to the light of pascal dusapin who
inhabit the space of this cathedral
the aïd to accompany each harmony
mixed wandering seizing by an
untraceable call  what the love of the nation
carries with transcendence breath of song
that turns the senses and we in the lace
punctuated by these names who pass their
name here says that they are regaining their
rights they are there those of 14
forming the procession of the brave who  are entering
the pantheon today
and the comrades of
genevois porsche
buts reyl cie copan are rising here are so many others
here are charles peguy alain fournier louis
aragon and jean giono joseph kessel and
guillaume apollinaire albert roche brave
among the brave who managed to hold on
only a trench facing the enemy marie
marvingt who wanted to defend her
country so much that she disguised herself as men to
fight in the front line maur  ice
marshal who in the din of the front
playing his makeshift cello made
of pieces of doors and a box of
ammunition lazare ponticelli italian
enlisted in the foreign legion who
became french and was the last of our
veterans fernand sattouf native of
beirut
enlisted  volunteer in the 2nd regiment of
zouaves in algiers abdoulaye n'diaye senegalese
skirmishers all these
soldiers from all our provinces from all our villages soldiers of the black army and
colonial troops from the
departments of algeria from the protectorates
of tunisia and morocco  of the
French colonies in Africa, India
and Indochina as well as our other
mayors across the Atlantic, the Indian Ocean
and the Pacific,
they are all there,
what they have done, written Geneva, it's
more than we  couldn't ask
men and they did it here they are
arriving by the millions to enter this
dome
let's listen to the march of the dead of notre
dame de lorette de verdun by old
armand and by  s dardanelles
all gather and approach yesterday
brothers in arms today companion
of eternity he advances in front of the temple
of the heroes of our fatherland
glories of the past are alive only
for the living countries warn jaurès of
those of 14  to those of today we
French are very much alive
our soil was the land of their
battles their love of freedom the
viaticum they bequeathed to us their
sacrifice says our debt and our duties
there was me among you their
Geneva writings  there was a swell among us
already long live the republic long
live france